marcus aurelius is constantly writing to
himself he's like look don't think about
how you might lose the things you love
in the future return to the present and
realize they're here right now and in
worrying about them you're missing out
on what's so good about them
so i want to start with a quote
are you not ashamed of your eagerness to
possess as much wealth reputation and
honors as possible while you do not care
nor give thought to wisdom or truth or
the best possible state of your soul
what's that mean to you
i can start so that's a very famous
passage from socrates's apology uh 2 400
years ago socrates the kind of founder
of philosophy
was put on trial by the athenian
government for among other things
corrupting the youth of athens for
asking too many hard questions and being
a bit too aggressive and pushy about
whether athens was pursuing the things
that were really valuable in life versus
just kind of inflating their own egos
and one of the things i love about that
quote we uh we shout that and read it to
undergraduates here at notre dame quite
a bit
you can imagine somebody saying to their
enemy or like their opposition you guys
don't care about the right things all
you care about is money or all you care
about is fame you don't care about
what's really good
but socrates uh is not saying that to
his enemies
he's saying it to his friends and
students that's one of the quotes that
got him into trouble is he's going
around to people he really cares about
and saying like
paul
i think you're getting too addicted to
these like cultural lies about money and
honor and i really think you need to
work harder on like going after things
that are really worth having and that
was a threatening idea in athens why was
it so threatening
well i mean so for one thing uh athens
is a direct democracy right uh and so
the ability to argue and the ability to
persuade people could be literally a
life or death matter right if somebody
got up and accused you of something uh
in front of uh uh the assembly you just
had to stand up and you had to argue you
had to say like this is you know why
this isn't true
uh or this is why somebody else owes me
a bunch of money or whatever it might be
and so the ability to just win arguments
at all costs is something that's a
really valuable skill and they're
actually professional you know we call
them argument or debate coaches they're
called the sophists right uh who would
be hired uh often by sort of the wealthy
uh uh in athens to train athenian
citizens on how to argue right uh and
it's easy to see how you might lose uh
the truth in all of that right or lose a
desire for the truth lose a love for the
truth uh because if it doesn't matter
you know whether your argument's true or
not if it just matters like whether
you're persuading people um there's not
really as much incentive right to focus
on uh you know whether your reasons that
you're giving are good um so this is one
of the reasons why i think socrates is
such a revolutionary figure both in his
own time and also ours i mean like as we
sort of did the research and we're right
looking at ancient athens i was just
struck by how many parallels there are
between you know the complaints that
socrates has about his own time and the
complaints that you know a lot of us
have when we sort of look at the the
state of political debate or the state
of uh debate on twitter and you know
people trying to
sort of own each other on twitter you
know just uh you know exert some sort of
power without any sort of respect for
love uh of the truth and that's you know
it's an over uh generalization it's not
always the case it's not what's always
going on um but it certainly resonates
right the message sort of resonates and
as i read you know socrates's critique i
just like constantly found myself
nodding along and thinking like yeah i
recognize this why did he end up being
killed then
yeah good this is the question from the
last 2400 years i mean so much
philosophy has been written starting
with his student plato about how did
this go so wrong this is one of things i
love about reading greek philosophy is
that you know you can empathize with
these guys
i don't know i suspect a lot of your
listeners are like me and you look
around it's 20 22 and you just think how
did we get here
like what exactly got us to the point
where this is what we're fighting about
in the news and this is how i'm living
my life
for you know allegedly the charges
against socrates were that he was
corrupting the youth
that he was encouraging uh atheism or
the or rejection of the greek religion
the weirdest one is that he worships
things below the earth
or he's too interested in things below
the earth and again it has even at his
time people were like what is his charge
um
you know one of the one of the
hypotheses that i think uh
makes the most sense to me
is put yourself in the shoes of the
athenians
to make decisions you have to do them
democratically and people have to vote
and i don't know if you're part of like
a local school board right now or if
you're part of an office that's deciding
your like policy for coming back to work
anytime you need people to vote to make
an important decision you really need
people to be lined up and together and
agreeing with each other otherwise it's
really really fraught and very painful
and stressful especially if you think
that the other a bad decision might get
made
and so for athens they made all their
big decisions we're going to war we're
going to levy a new tax they made all
the decisions that way
and somebody like socrates going around
encouraging people to question the
status quo or question the culture is
going to be once you see it working and
it worked like you got people to think
like maybe i'm not so right maybe i
shouldn't believe what the louder guy's
telling me um then you also start to
lose confidence that we're able to vote
on anything anymore and and that can be
really scary if there's a lot on the
line i think too just to kind of jump in
here you know one of the the really
powerful moments in the apology is where
socrates is given the choice to either
go free right he can totally go free but
they say if you go free like you can't
keep asking questions right you can't
keep doing this thing that you've been
doing uh or we're gonna kill you like
those are your choices right uh and of
course he chooses to die he says the
unexamined life is not worth living this
is something that like we put on
stickers here is that his response is
that his response during the trial
yeah it comes in the apology yeah he
says that is a [ __ ] boss move like
what an unbelievable response if you
think that's that's great i mean the
other thing they say is like well what
do you think your sentence should be if
not death and he says you guys should
give me free lunch for the rest of my
life he literally says
he was kind of trolling them i mean at
this point he was totally trolling them
he knew where this is going yeah yeah um
but i think one of the reasons that's so
powerful for me is because you know
a way of uh focusing in on what you
think are the most important goals in
life or the most important good things
in life right is just to ask like
what are the things that if i didn't
have them my life wouldn't be worth
living you know aristotle famously says
you know without friends a man would not
choose to live though he had every other
good
and to me you know that just strikes me
right i think like yeah gosh you can
imagine somebody who's you know totally
wealthy they have you know they're
physically fit and healthy and
everything else they don't have any
friends you think there's something
deeply lacking in that life right and so
in choosing
not to continue to live if he can't
engage in this kind of questioning if
you can't pursue the truth with other
people in his community socrates is
really just saying like this is the
ultimate good this is the ultimate goal
in my life and if you're gonna take that
away from me you might as well take my
life too
that like i don't know even now like
gives me chills it sort of you know is
the reason why i think philosophy
professors see him as sort of the the
martyr uh kind of hero figure uh in
philosophy uh and i think you know it's
a worthwhile thought experiment for us
too just to think like you know what are
those good things in our life that we'd
be either willing to give up our life
for or that just you know without which
we would say yeah our life is is not
worth living or is certainly not as good
as it is now i think and this can kind
of sound like you know literature uh not
realizing that this is a real
uh a real trade-off that people face
even now so i was really moved this
summer
reading about faculty members in
philosophy departments in hong kong who
are faced with this decision of going to
jail if they continue to teach certain
kinds of political philosophy
or uh if they're willing to stop
teaching that then they can keep their
jobs and what type of philosophy is it
uh philosophy about liberal democracy so
like john rawls and uh
like western style
arguments about how decisions should be
made in a democratic liberal republic uh
rawls in particular is kind of the
flashpoint because he's on a lot of
curricula
and there are faculty members who um are
threatened directly with the government
with jail sentences or losing their jobs
who i think are pretty brave i read this
and thought like gosh what would i do
like
would i be willing to change my class to
avoid going to jail or what i think like
there's no point in me claiming i'm a
philosopher
or living in this world if i can't if i
can't ask the questions that i think we
need answers to
that socratic sacrifice is a good way to
kick off any subject area right like if
that's the guy
that was you know that's your jesus
christ it's gonna make some pretty
badass people downstream from that i
didn't even know that about hong kong
because they're not hong kong a separate
independent of china right or is there
some chinese influence that's coming
over the top of that which is causing
issues
it's quite complicated at the moment
this is definitely not an area where i'm
an expert i've had the chance to spend
some time at these universities in hong
kong doing philosophy and they have
really vibrant totally amazing
philosophy departments but yeah the the
um the mainland mainland china and the
people's republic is uh taking over more
and more uh governing control over hong
kong as a part of this process of
britain giving up control
and so we're facing some really hard
questions about what what the nature of
education is um i mean this is just two
very different mindsets about what's
really valuable and and it's like you
know it's it's institutionalized in
these particular people having to make
hard decisions one thing yeah that this
reminds me of is uh there's this great
series of episodes on this american life
about hong kong and about what's going
on uh and it's actually just fascinating
again i know nothing about uh the
political situation in hong kong but uh
but one thing that comes out in that
series is just uh how education
is a flashpoint as you're saying it's
kind of um it's got this power right
like what you're teaching in the schools
it's got this generational power
uh which you know is humbling to think
about in our own context because i think
it's easy to get lost in all the
different debates that we have in
academia or wherever else um but it you
know it does hold the kind of power what
you're teaching what you're learning
what kind of community you're building
up with people that you're asking
questions with it's got political uh
impacts and i think the critical thing
to remember about socrates is it's not
that he was willing to die for a
particular belief i mean there are a lot
of there are a lot of academics and a
lot of people with with ideas that i
think it would be horrible if they said
they'd be willing to die for them
because their ideas could be wrong
they could be dumb people have dumb
ideas all the time
socrates was willing to die for the
right to ask questions like the right to
try to figure out the truth and to be
satisfied about the truth and that is
worth
um defending at great lengths but but
not necessarily saying like if you don't
believe me on this particular
philosophical theory i'm gonna burn this
place to the ground that's that's
antithetical to philosophy yeah it's so
fundamental right there was a
a conversation i had
a couple of months ago to do with free
speech and
where free speech begins and ends and
there was a justification that the only
type of speech which shouldn't be
permitted is that which further
restricts free speech so if you try to
employ your free speech to limit other
people's ability to use free speech that
actually starts to cross a line because
it's inherently self-defeating and
that's kind of what you're talking about
here it's not necessarily a particular
point of view with regards to a type of
philosophy it is the process that
undergirds the ability to do philosophy
itself it's like saying like you're not
allowed to do philosophy that would be
one of the implications of it so rolling
the clock forward to what you guys are
doing now what does this have to do with
leading a good life
yes we actually talk about this in the
first chapter of the book we talk about
uh all of the adventures we've had in uh
in teaching philosophy over the last
four years where we try to ask these
really
really hard questions to hundreds and
hundreds of 18 year olds and kind of
like light the match
and watch what happens well i think one
thing that we've learned and we really
try to share this with the reader in the
first chapter
is a lot of folks are frustrated right
now by realizing that they have pretty
persistent disagreements with other
people about hot button issues about
racism about how to handle a global
health emergency
and they think that uh you know
strategies that we get recommended to us
one strategy which i feel like i read
about all the time in the new york times
in the chronicle of higher education is
how to mold people's minds to agree with
you using like subtle techniques so how
to like get paul to come around on
wearing a mask by using rhetorical
tricks it's like oh my gosh this is
sophistry like that this is totally um
not the ethical way to treat people who
disagree with you
another approach is like
why your arguments are better than the
people who disagree with you and how to
know that your arguments are better and
that's also
not going to help you make any progress
at trying to figure out how we can all
get on the same page and improve our
beliefs
plato in the republic one just talks
about how frustrated he is with trying
to argue with people who spend all their
time thinking about winning arguments
uh but then he also says we have another
option
which is to first like remind ourselves
when we start to get into these fights
why we care in the first place about
this issue and like why it matters to us
to get it right rather than just to win
plato has his students in the academy
doing all these exercises like math
problems to just remind themselves that
they still like getting the right answer
uh even if it wasn't the answer they
initially started out with and he thinks
that like cultivating that feeling of
like wanting the right answer rather
than defending the answer you currently
have is it's a better option
and then we get this allegory of the
cave in the republic where he's like
what if there's like better answers
about absolutely everything and not just
math problems and what if like if you
tried harder you might get those as well
and how much how beautiful would it be
to be outside the cave how much better
would it be to be outside the cave with
your friends and not just by yourself
and starting to kind of we call it fear
of missing out but philosophical fear of
missing out like if you if you kind of
feel like there could be something
better
that we could achieve by cooperative
discuss discussion of this issue
aimed at the truth rather than just
trying to win the argument then
maybe uh maybe wanting that would help
decrease some of the tension
i think too so the the way that i uh
sort of experience
you know the method that socrates is
employing and in some ways this is
related to you know even the title of
our book the good life method like uh
thinking about you know rightly ordering
the values that you have
in pursuing the truth or you know in in
thinking about what matters in your life
and what your goals should be uh the way
i connect it with with our contemporary
especially like our very contemporary
situation is you know maybe 10 years ago
or so
i used to read a lot of op-eds uh that
had the following form they would say
like look we all disagree about things
but as long as we get all the views out
there on the table we're eventually like
the truth is going to rise to the top
and we're just going to figure it out
right and then it turns out that uh when
people start making arguments with no
regard for the truth at all this
strategy just doesn't work right uh in
the book we we call this you know after
um harry frank for you know calls this
[ __ ] right just making arguments
without any concern for the truth at all
it's just [ __ ] right so you know you
can't have a policy a personal policy or
sort of an institutional policy that
just says look we take every single
argument that comes out there and we put
them at exactly the same level and
eventually we're all gonna agree there's
gonna be a consensus uh now where that
does work is if you have some shared
value underlying you know the arguments
that are getting on the table and here's
how i think about it and experience it i
argue with my mom like all the time like
this is like the way that we show that
we love each other as we you know call
each other up we're like here's this
article about something and you know i
think you're wrong about this and we go
back and forth and the reason i think it
works for us whereas it definitely
doesn't work for me on twitter or on
facebook or you know on social media is
that my mom and i care both about each
other but also about the truth like we
genuinely you know not not always i mean
yeah it's like easy to kind of get into
a position where you're like i just want
to be right but we really care we really
think look we're both going to be better
off if we know the truth about this even
if that means that you're wrong even if
it means that i'm wrong if it means
we're both wrong
so i think you know i don't have a like
deep diagnosis of like why we're so
politically polarized or why we've
gotten to a position where you know we
use argumentational [ __ ] uh to just
kind of like push the different
positions that we have to try to change
politics or our community or whatever it
might be i don't know why exactly that
is uh but i do know that that you know
plato and socrates and aristotle are on
to something where they say part of the
problem a huge part of the problem is
that we just don't have this really
fundamental attitude a love for the
truth and it's something that that we
don't have in relationship and in
community with other people and if we
have that if we can rediscover that or
re-awaken it it's going to make a huge
difference i think the problem is that
you have perverse incentives going on
here if somebody was constrained by the
truth
then their argumentation would be less
effective because the race to the bottom
is the person that isn't constrained by
the truth can use more limbically
hijacking language or they can be more
inflammatory or they can understand
neuro-linguistic programming or whatever
tactic it is that they need to be more
effective if you decide to play if i
decide to play football and i'm
constrained by the rules of football but
you decide to pick it up and run with it
under your arm like it's rugby then i i
there is an asymmetry in terms of how
effective we can be at playing this game
because you've decided not to play by
the rules so yeah there's two ways to do
it right one way would be to say we need
to have very very hard and fast rules
about the game that makes it incr highly
sanctioned if you decide to pick the
ball up and run with it under your arm
the alternative which is what you guys
are suggesting is to have an emergent
bottom up social uh enforcement
mechanism where all of the players on
the field would stop and go mate you
can't you can't pick the ball up stop
being a dick so you have sort of this
top-down or bottom-up approach but yeah
i think increasingly at the moment the
bottom-up approach
because of how tribal everybody is no
one wants to restrict their own team's
ability to win
and generally at the moment there is
such an anti-authoritarian like what
gets called authoritarian now there are
some authoritarian policies out there
but it's a word that gets used an awful
lot to describe like any type of
intervention that occurs from the top so
it's kind of hard to work out how to
just get people playing by the rules of
the game again well and this is why
again you totally need socrates and you
understand why he was in such a bind at
the end of the apology
because
you very well could decide i care about
the truth i'm going to be willing to
change my mind i think a big cultural
problem we have right now is if somebody
um looks like they change their mind
about an issue that they really care
about they get beat up like people just
so true gross
saying i'm wrong will get you fired um
it'll get you canceled so
uh but you can be the kind of person who
thinks like caring about the truth
is so important to me that even in a
completely screwed up system where i'm
not going to win football games as a
result of it or where i might put my job
at risk that's why socrates is saying
you got to care about this
more than your job you've got to care
about this more than winning um it's got
it's got to be that important because to
to make it a part of your life you're
you're going to take some risks
part of the living philosophically and
living a good life doesn't mean that
you're just going to get everything so
aside from the avoiding culture war
topics and stuff like that how have you
guys defined what a good life means what
does a good life mean to you
yeah that's a i mean
one of the the sort of structuring
principles that we used in writing the
book is you know we tried to look at
different uh what we call virtues we you
know we're working in a virtue ethics
tradition uh but i should maybe just
just sort of say you know the way that
we're thinking about virtues here is as
human excellences you know so we're
thinking about virtues in the way that
aristotle thinks about virtues uh so
what are the traits of character what
are the the habits uh of soul you know
if you want to put it sort of in
different language that are required to
flourish as a person to be happy and so
one of the way that we organize the book
is you know each of the chapters looks
at a different virtue uh or a different
kind of class of virtues um so we go
through you know the beginning of the
book we talk about the love of truth uh
we talk about generosity and the ways
that you know people think differently
about generosity and what it means to be
a generous person
how you should structure and order your
financial life we talk about love and
attention and care how should you relate
to the people in your life
uh and responsibility is one of my
favorite ones uh and how you can take
personal responsibility for things so so
we go through these right each of the
chapters is kind of um a picture of a
virtue and and hopefully one that you
can see related uh to an actual life we
give a lot of personal stories as we go
through and say look this is how we
think about generosity you know
theoretically like as philosophers but
this is how we try to live it out in our
actual lives
and so what we're hoping emerges is you
know a picture of
what we think are you know really
important virtues for a good life so
that our readers can kind of see that
see themselves reflected in each of
those stories and then critically
evaluate and say like yeah that is how i
think about generosity too or no totally
not i think you guys are wrong you say
that a uh a remarkable feature about
human history is that we all started
wondering philosophically about how to
live better lives at roughly the same
time between 600 and 300 bc
why do you think that happened
we've gotten that question once or twice
now and i feel like this is where we
show how little we know about the
history of the world um
we should say you know we probably
should have qualified that the book of
like that's at least when the written
records all start popping up so you got
confucius and the jew dynasty you've got
buddha working in
in southeast asia
you've got the jewish wisdom tradition
that's really getting fired up and
writing like job and ecclesiastes and
starting to think really hard about this
whole god question in a philosophical
way and then you got your socrates plato
aristotle dream team operating in greece
and it is i mean 300 years is actually
not that long it's a drop in the bucket
for humans and so it's pretty nuts that
just you know spanning a bunch of
different parts of the world
they're all uh issuing theories that uh
are different in some respects but the
core operating system is shockingly
similar
humans have a certain way that we are
right now
there's a human 2.0 like a version of us
that would be better and that we can't
help but worry about and want to be
but we don't quite know how to get from
where we are to what that version is and
we're not even 100 sure aristotle talks
about being an archer who kind of sees
the target off in the distance but
doesn't have good enough vision to know
exactly how to hit it or exactly what it
looks like and folks think we're going
to need philosophy and we're going to
need systems of education to try to
figure out this target and we're going
to be miserable if we don't find it um
and that then then it gets weird
obviously like buddhists have very
different vision of the target than um
than
the greek philosophers do and confucius
is not a hundred percent
clear about whether everyone has that
target or it's really just people in the
jew dynasty
that need to hit their target um so it's
not to like try to lump them all
together but this that there's this kind
of recipe let's start developing schools
and training systems and try to be a lot
more systematic about figuring out what
it is that we're trying to become
uh
that's pretty freaking cool and some of
these cultures are interacting with each
other but it's not like they're right on
top of each other um so it's a that's a
bit of like the mystery aspect of like
what was going on in human development
where we're all just kind of turning
onto this stage at the same time yeah
and one of the things that we talk about
in the book and that aristotle talks uh
about ad nauseam like across all the
texts that he writes is that uh you know
reflecting on our lives as a means of
improving them is something that's just
baked into us right he thought this is
like our function or like part of our
nature uh that we are self-reflective
reason-directed creatures right we want
to think about how to get better i love
you know the example that megan often
gives about this like you know dogs
don't do this they don't they don't sort
of wake up and they think man how could
i be better at fetching right let me
read a book about fetching they just
like they fetch and they're either great
at it or they're terrible at it right uh
but human beings we we use the intellect
we use our mind
and we do it in community with other
people through conversation
uh to get better right and so i think
that's just uh uh sort of fascinating
evidence that aristotle was certainly
onto something and you know figures in
these other traditions that talk about
it as well but there's just something
really attractive right all humans
by nature desire to know like this is a
quote from from the beginning of uh the
metaphysics uh by aristotle all humans
desire by nature to know that's just a
value that's baked in i don't know i
think that resonates and i think it's
sort of yeah evidenced by all of these
different
traditions popping up at the same time i
love the way plato plato and the
protagoras is giving has socrates uh
giving this speech about how you really
need to start teaching your kids math
and philosophy like do it early and he's
talking with his friends and his friends
are like why is this such a big deal for
you and he's like look you know this is
a paraphrase obviously but he's like
animals have a lot of advantages they've
got fur they've got sharp teeth they've
got a lot going for them and this whole
survival game just that's just given to
them but we are uh furless
toothless kind of awkwardly designed
creatures featherless bipeds the only
thing we have is our wits and so if your
kids don't develop that like the ability
to kind of make far sighted plans and
trade-offs that's what they're talking
about in that passage um we are screwed
like we're not gonna make it he's the
only the only advantage that we've got
in this game have you seen there's a
meme of a guy and a dog next to an open
landscape and there's a thought bubble
coming out of the guy and it's a
computer and it's a car and it's a money
tree and it's other [ __ ] and coming out
of the dog it's just a small
representation of the landscape that
they're seeing right it's like a comment
on the fact that the reason that the dog
is happy is because the dog is able to
be present and the human's unhappiness
is because he's constantly ruminating
about all of the [ __ ] that he needs to
do there's something about that that
that kind of triggers me a little bit i
always feel it
regularly comes up and it always makes
me feel a little bit i don't know just
pissed off because
like implied in that is
if we were able to
tune our
cognition down to some sort of more base
level we would be happier that the dog
is somehow superior or it it's the dogs
got it right because it made the choice
it's like no no no
it is working at its maximum capacity
the dog is thinking about going for
fetch without trying to become better at
playing fetch because it can't think of
that if it was burdened with the depth
of thought that humans have it would
have all of the ruminations and all of
the
awful reflections that we do as well
there's something about that that
always pisses me off i don't know why
i love that i i think uh uh and i love
that like you get mad at this i i do the
same thing i look at these memes i was
like come on
uh
i think
you know i i think one thing that's
interesting that this just really calls
to mind for me is um the stoic tradition
right so we talk about stoicism at the
end of the book uh and about how
human beings they can sort of capture
what's good about you know what's
happening with the dog but we do it in a
really distinctive way right we do it in
a contemplative sort of way
and so here's here's what that means
look yeah we've got all this other stuff
going on and it's a huge advantage like
i would never give up the ability to
like you know rationally think about my
life and organize it and appreciate in
an intellectual way like what i love
about my family and all these other
things they're just incredible things
okay but there's a bunch of downsides
there's a bunch of terrible stuff that
comes along with that right uh loving my
son but also knowing that like the world
could intervene and frustrate this in
some way gives me deep anxiety about the
future right uh and that's the downside
right so you know it's great that we can
think there's this downside okay so what
do we do about that fact
one of the things that's really
fascinating about stoicism and the
stoics is they say the answer to that
problem is philosophy right uh what
you're supposed to do is you're supposed
to
come up with meditations or exercises or
ways of intellectually contemplatively
putting yourself in touch with reality
not again not not in the way that the
dog is i think the meme is mistaken even
in like you know attributing this as a
thought of the dog i mean the dog isn't
there's no representation uh actually
sorry i'm gonna get out of like the
philosophy of mind of animals but uh you
know it's just it's just boom it's just
there whatever well for human beings
right uh uh one of the things that we
can do is we can look at our
representation of the way things are i
might lose you know my son in the future
be estranged from him or whatever and we
can use our contemplative capacities to
make sure that those are attuned to
reality in the right sort of way right
so marcus aurelius is constantly writing
to himself he's like look don't think
about how you might lose the things you
love in the future like return to the
present and realize
they're here right now and in worrying
about them you're missing out on what's
so good about them that you could be
present to them that you can be sort of
uh tethered to reality in the right sort
of way so one thing that's just you know
fascinating to me about about the stoics
and a lot of traditions uh in philosophy
around the time they're writing is that
they think that you know the answer to
the problems that arise with
intellectual capacity is actually to go
through those capacities to go through
contemplation uh and aristotle writes
about contemplation at great length and
i do think that's actually something
that in our culture we sometimes sort of
lose right we think of i don't know
contemplation is this weird isolated
monastic sort of thing that like some
weirdos do but like i'm not gonna i'm
not gonna do that uh but really like you
know the stoics aristotle they think no
no this is absolutely central for
dealing with exactly the the kind of
problems that that you're referencing
well think about what most people are
trying to do or what a lot of people are
trying to do with their daily lives
either consciously or subconsciously
they're trying to escape from that
contemplative practice they're using
caffeine to make themselves moves faster
or alcohol to make themselves move
slower and down regulate the resolution
that they see the world with phones to
distract themselves and netflix and sex
and
extreme sports and you know pick your
pursuit naval rabbicant has a quote
where he says we don't want peace of
mind we want peace from mind and that
distinction of us just
uh paul bloom who you may know a
psychologist from yale now in toronto
he's interviewed a dominatrix and she
said nothing captures attention like a
whip
and what she meant was that if you get
slapped in the face for the next five
seconds you don't think about anything
and that's a very rare but beautiful
situation to be in a
bizarre way looking down the
pipe of a dominatrix wearing leather
with a whip and a hand um but it's true
right you have this opportunity to
escape the ruminations from your mind
and this is i think again like that's
what the
person that made that meme is is trying
to create look
if only we could be like the dog if only
we could dial back the resolution that
we see things with
you've mentioned just to thought come up
there you mentioned stoicism an awful
lot
i've had a ton of
stoic uh scholars on the show ryan
holliday
massimo piglucci donald robertson
what is it about stoicism that's made it
so sexy
in the modern era like why is
epicureanism or taoism or you know
cynicism why why are there no other
renaissances and do you think if you
could put a couple of bets if you could
invest in some different philosophies do
you think that we'll see a renaissance
for some other ones coming soon
i can start off on this so i've got i've
got my own potted theory about why
stoicism is having its moment but first
the first thing i'll say one of the
things we try to show in the book is
that stoicism is part of this much
bigger longer more interesting and
variegated tradition in philosophy
called virtue ethics which gets going
with the greeks you find versions of it
in china but if if you really like the
general thrust
so system but you don't like some of the
recommendations or some of the goals
seem shallow to you that's okay because
it's you know there's other versions of
this kind of philosophy that you might
find a lot more use out of and so
uh we encourage you to think about
stoicism in context of this bigger kind
of philosophy
i think stoicism is really um exciting
and appealing to a lot of folks in the
united states right now
because first the stoics
the stoics are
about finding ways to uh thrive in
hostile environments
so
uh marcus aurelius seneca
these guys were all dealing with the
hot dumpster fire that was the roman
empire um they they were important men
of like public life so i mean some
stoics were were full-time
whack-a-doodle philosophers but a lot of
them were people with day jobs like
significant prominent honor inducing day
jobs
but who also had the big kind of
problems and this philosophical view
seemed to help them thrive in light of
challenges rather than being pummeled by
them and
you know you look at all of the change
that's even happened during our
lifetimes the fact that the internet has
totally revolutionized every aspect of
how we think and interact and
communicate that's happened just the
last two decades that's crazy
um the way that we've dealt with
political you know
changes the fact that we're in a mature
empire that's having its own kinds of
puzzles
um still us that we can see a lot of
ourselves in these romans who were
dealing with their problems and we might
want to see that we're like them because
they they did okay and like marcus
aurelius did okay in the end
i think also there are some really uh
helpful psychological therapies that the
stoic suggested and then modern
psychology is made really effective
probably the most obvious one is
cognitive behavioral therapy this idea
of you're facing anxiety which we all do
and you might have thought that you just
have to live with it or it's your own
problem
but in fact there are exercises that you
can undertake to start to control your
emotions negative emotions um and stokes
took that extraordinarily seriously and
i think a lot of us find ourselves in
this situation right now where we want
that we want that benefit
yeah and let me make so i'll make a
prediction and that is that uh i think
virtue ethics is uh in one way or
another the thing that sort of comes
next and here's why i think it so i
think i think megan's totally right that
stoicism you know gives us these
practices these meditations that are
empirically grounded uh but it also
gives us a bit of substance a bit of
philosophical substance uh to sort of
grab onto and say you know not only does
this breathing technique work for me uh
but it also connects up with my purpose
as a human being and it connects up with
this rational sort of contemplative
nature
now one thing that's really crucial to
the stoic picture uh and that i guess i
would you know really push a stoic you
know contemporary stoic on if i you know
if i had a chance to talk to them is
the stoics actually have some pretty
crazy views in the background the reason
they're so optimistic that if you get in
touch with reality your anxiety is going
to go down is because they think the
cosmos is divinely ordered right uh and
a lot of contemporary stokes say well
you know okay we'll take some of that or
we won't take some of that or maybe it's
metaphorical or whatever it might be
uh one thing that's really cool about
virtue ethics and about you know the
various different forms it takes is that
uh there are versions of it uh that that
sort of don't assume substantively uh
some of these pictures these
metaphysical pictures that i think a lot
of a lot of people today don't assume
right some people do and you can kind of
plug in sort of theistic pictures to
stoicism or whatever or even look at
like augustine and see how he tried to
you know manage that kind of stuff but a
lot of people you know if you're just
like you know a secular person out in
the world looking for a great philosophy
a lot of the stoicism resonates but then
you start thinking gosh like i don't
know if i think that you know there's
this sort of cosmos that's divinely
ordered and whatever else there's news
that we all share i don't know
so my thought is you know if you if you
keep digging philosophically uh virtue
ethics is just this incredible territory
uh where you can start coming up with
resources and tools to come up with a
substantive philosophical picture um
that you actually that you believe that
you think is you know this is the right
picture and of course aristotle has this
you know he's got a view of human nature
and our function our purpose um again
you know going into augustine you know
the christian philosophical tradition
has these uh but again i think as people
continue to look for more and more
substantive philosophical views behind
the things that they find really useful
and and helpful i think you know they're
going to find that the virtue tradition
is just totally you know full of these
rich pictures uh that yeah that are that
are really appealing in their own way
what do you think is a tool or a couple
of tools that virtue ethics has which
stoicism is missing massively
i think you know just really distinctive
pictures of the human person right
and distinctive pictures just practical
pictures of how we can take something
like our view of what we think we are
what we think our functional purpose is
and then translate that into really
practical advice right if you look at
the nicomachean ethics from aristotle uh
and the nikhil kinetics is really
fascinating right the form of the book
is it's actually either lecture notes
that he sort of wrote or that somebody
that was taking his class wrote uh on a
class that he was giving about how to be
happy how to achieve eudaimonia right
how to flourish as a human being and so
if you look at it yeah there's really
abstract theoretical stuff right at the
beginning he says look i'm going to give
you an argument about what your function
is about what the purpose and meaning of
life is and then immediately we jump
into and here's a virtue that you know
in in light of that fact you've got to
acquire and here's what it looks like
here's what friendship looks like uh and
he's giving arguments right he's not
just saying trust me he's saying here's
my argument about why friendship is
really important he does that for you
know most of the book he's looking at
these really practical issues giving you
arguments and then he ends up kind of
like zooming back and saying okay so
let's like tie this all together uh and
let's look at you know what this entails
in the very end uh but for me i mean
that that's that's you know it sort of
shows the power of virtue ethics you can
have this really substantive theoretical
view
but you immediately get into just really
practical issues really practical advice
uh about the things that we care about
about how you should spend money or
raise your kids uh or you know whether
you should practice a religion whatever
it might be kind of the way that those
big questions sort of show up or appear
in our daily lives or experience um to
me that's i don't know that's that's one
of the huge sort of strengths of virtue
ethics i think one one thing i found a
little bit irritating about the kind of
contemporary american version of
stoicism that's really popular right now
is if you ask them kind of what the goal
is we talked about trying to figure out
that target that you're trying to hit
with your arrow
a lot of times it sounds to me and this
might be a little bit uncharitable like
the goal is kind of invincibility like
to make myself immune from bad things
that might happen i would have said
indifference but yeah invincibility
might be a way to put it
and again i don't know about you like
that's not my goal i when i think about
what a really good person is sometimes
it's somebody that makes extraordinary
sacrifices for others
um and uh in ways that it's not going to
attribute back to their own glory and
like has this kind of concept of a comic
and this marcus really certainly thinks
stuff like this too something is fair to
necessarily pin it to the romans but
when you listen to some of the stoic
technology driven a metaphysical
self-help advice right now it's like i'm
going to use stoicism to make sure that
i win every argument with my board
and it's like no man the whole point of
it was like
you are mortal
um and you are
a non-fur non-sharp teeth-covered
organism that depends on other people
and good reason in order to do well
and it would be better if you um if you
were a little bit more vulnerable like
there are some really great goods that
come from uh
come from
suffering for other people and allowing
suffering to happen to you and i think
that you know certainly like christians
in rome at the time were were really
critical
of how into the into this the roman
empire was getting because it was also
making the roman empire cold yeah
that's the that's the thing
that i struggle to kind of pass out
stoicism doesn't seem to have a ton of
joy in it to me or certainly not
i'm not going to try and be like an
advocate for your philosophy needs to
account for hedonism but you know people
like to party we like to find pleasure
in the moment and it it seems like there
aren't really
much room
for that
in stoicism
one of the things that shocked me as i
went back and read uh marcus aurelius
this this like last time and i i read
the meditations like every a couple of
months now because i teach it in
different classes one of the things that
shocked me is right you know at the
beginning of the meditations he's giving
a list of people that he's grateful for
and the things that he's learned for
them and one of them i forget who he's
talking about he says you know i'm
grateful that he showed me how to be the
same man in all conditions even during
the like this period where he had lost a
child and i read that i was just like
whoa dude back up like you know uh to be
totally indifferent to something like
that like that struck me as as you know
um kind of not monstrous but you know
the wrong way to go right so so to have
the resources to say look there are
times where it makes sense to
tie your happiness up with the happiness
of another person there are you know
ways in which we flourish and we're
happy only if we're flourishing together
uh that to me is a really powerful idea
and i think you know we can swing sort
of too far to one end or the other and
we can start thinking well our happiness
consists in you know being super wealthy
or having these external goods and okay
now we're going you know in the wrong
direction but again one thing that i
think you know virtue ethics provides
the resources for is is just to kind of
balance out uh some of some of that kind
of the the pejorative sense of stoicism
that you know uh you sometimes hear
people talking about um which i do think
is you know it's a real danger what role
do you think that truth has in the good
life then
yeah i mean
well yes i going all the way back to
socrates
you know
i find
our students uh will often tell us that
the the line that we uh quoted from
socrates at the beginning is the thing
that really sticks with them after the
class right the unexamined life is not
worth living uh it's this idea that's
again shocking uh especially in our time
sort of a deeper commitment to the truth
than even to my own goals in life or to
you know uh winning arguments online or
whatever else um i take that just really
really seriously i think um if i can
become the kind of person
who cares more about the truth than
winning arguments who cares more about
the truth um then you know my status or
whatever it might be if i can become a
little bit more socratic in that way
uh
i think um you know that's a sort of
like socrates serves as an exemplar here
um uh for me you know for those reasons
um
yeah i think i've been reflecting a lot
and we write about this a little bit in
the book about the elizabeth holmes
trial you know she was just convicted on
foreign we were writing about her when
we were writing about william james a
year ago and we were working on the
manuscript and we were thinking man this
whole news cycle is going to be over by
the time this book comes out nobody's
going to care about our philosophical
nailed it week of release nailed it yeah
yeah we totally nailed it but you know
we have uh up in the office where i work
at notre dame we have some pretty
vigorous debates about how a good person
should feel about that trial if your
readers or listeners don't remember
elizabeth holmes was this very young
uh medical device entrepreneur in
silicon valley who dropped out of
stanford and started heavily marketing
this blood testing technology she was
trying to develop to use really small
amounts of blood to determine various
diseases
and like everybody she got caught up in
this uh culture that values like fake it
till you make it like just pitch really
hard and you can you can your dreams can
outstrip reality with respect to
technology and
she raised all this money and walgreens
started like trying out her blood
testing technology and the whole thing
fell apart because at the end of the day
her blood tests don't work like she
can't get accurate data
and uh
you
you reflect on her case and you one
psychologically and culturally you
totally understand how she got into this
mess because we
um there are so many really tempting
advantages to being somebody who uh who
just wants something to be real but
doesn't care that much about whether or
not it's true
and there are so many success stories
like steve jobs
like it worked he lived this way he
lived his life this way and worked out
for him
but
uh one of the reasons why we think it's
really important to
to pause and make philosophy part of
your life and why we think it's
desperately important that kids be
taught it at elite colleges before they
go work for companies in silicon valley
is uh you can't you can't believe that
myth like you have to you have to
believe that there's some truth out
there that's worth like making the
anchor of your decision making or
otherwise you know practically speaking
you might end up in federal prison in
san francisco um but even just like you
know speaking for for your her soul and
other like entrepreneurs and founders is
like you might end up being the bad guy
in history like the person who sold
everybody snake oil
um but let's let's tune that up a little
bit more think about the fact that over
the next 100 years we're
moderately likely i would give it maybe
a 50 chance that we're going to see
super intelligent general artificial
intelligence right over the next 100
years 50 chance
if that is done by somebody who is more
concerned about being first than being
right the control problem and the
alignment problem are not going to be
fixed and we're all going to be paper
clips like we're going to be
nick bostrom's nightmare so
if that happens
this is you're so right like
when the externalities of your decisions
begin to become civilizational collapse
you need to have a more fundamental
grounded
um emergent idea that everybody agrees
on to do with how the world should be
run and
trying to
think what is good for humanity at large
when you can impact humanity you know
it's all well and good think about the
fact that socrates was talking about
this and who could he impact the people
that were within his
the field that his voice could reach
that's it you know the guy didn't even
have a megaphone let alone the ability
to completely rework every piece of
electronics on the planet to kill us
no it's totally true this actually gives
me uh some optimism for philosophy at
least as a field one of the things we
talk about in the book is
in the 20th century virtue ethics really
got this huge boost
right around the time of world war ii
and afterwards
and what a really concrete reason that
happened was nobody saw the atomic bomb
coming
and nobody saw like complete total war
fascism coming and then they happened
really fast and people realized
holy cow we better have a kind of
ethical theory and a sense of ethical
goals that is going to be able to cope
now with living in a world where you
could wipe everybody off the planet um
with the wrong program and then you see
like iris murdoch and elizabeth anscombe
and philip a foot and all these
philosophers rushing in to think okay
like we need to think about this so we
need to think about how we're going to
redial because the game has changed and
philosophy is really good again at that
like
goal-finding
activities hopefully for the good i mean
you could also imagine fly like you know
fascism was also fueled by a kind of
philosophy um so we hope we get it right
but you definitely can't have this
technological advance without the
accompanying philosophy yeah and just
even you know going all the way back to
socrates you know he's often described
as a gadfly as sort of somebody who is
able to to some extent stand outside
kind of dominant narratives in the
culture uh and sort of just pick at them
and just say you guys are like are we
really sure uh that this is the thing
that we want or you know are the
arguments that we're making that like
you know this tech platform is gonna you
know transform the world for the better
like is that right like like what are
the assumptions here about what kind of
people we are about uh what kind of
community that we want to actually have
uh what are the assumptions are and are
those true and so you know one thing
that gives me a bit of optimism is you
know that's something that like you
mentioned he could just do on his own it
was it's sort of you can form yourself
you can you know again we use the
language of craft your soul uh by doing
a little bit of philosophy knowing a
little bit of philosophy and then you
know doing some exercises or doing some
meditations you can sort of change
yourself so that you're disposed
to care about and stand up for the truth
uh in circumstances where it might be
incredibly difficult there might be a
lot of social pressure not to right yeah
i mean that's that's what we were
talking about at the very beginning
right the fact that you have uh would
you say
competing
narratives and competing influences on
people that makes changing your mind or
having a nuanced view or being anything
that isn't one extreme or the other
there are very very few do you know who
scott adams is the guy that wrote the
dilbert creator oh yeah yeah do you
follow him on twitter
okay
all right that's good that's for the
benefit of your sanity so scott adams um
was very pro-trump he was very sort of
right of center with a lot of things
over the last
couple of years right
however he's incredibly skeptical around
this vaccine skepticism stuff that we're
seeing that's coming out on the internet
at the moment and this is just spurging
his entire audience out he's getting
ratioed every single tweet on twitter
he's getting annihilated because his
audience can't
work out they patent matched him as
being this one person and then when he
rolls forward and doesn't continue to
follow their
projected trajectory for him they just
lose their [ __ ] and he's getting i feel
bad for the guy like you thought that
you had this person in your corner but
the reason that you liked him was
because he was able to arrive at a place
that was
independent and and um it was heterodox
at least for what a lot of people from
his background were thinking about you
know popular writers and stuff like that
and now he's done the same thing again
but because it doesn't align with your
interests
you don't like it yeah yeah
and think about like the incentive
structure there i don't know this is
something i think about sometimes
because you see it a lot right you see
somebody who like rises to prominence
because they've got they're speaking
some sort of uncomfortable truth or
they're talking about something that a
lot of people uh want to be talking
about and then all of a sudden there's
an orthodoxy that forms around that very
quickly and the minute they apply that
same sort of reasoning and they say hey
i'm going to be open-minded and think
about uh some other other topic like
you're saying
no no we co-opted you about this one
you're one of our tribe now
and and the thing that really strikes me
is so from their perspective okay once
you've climbed to the top of twitter or
wherever it is you know gotten a job in
politics or whatever it is that you you
wanted to do
there is so
much of a temptation to you know just
use that power or to kind of ride that
wave or say okay yeah you're right you
know what i will sort of pander whatever
it uh might be and that's kind of a
cultural you know sort of a sort of
cultural sickness or whatever it might
be uh but again you know what can we do
about that as individuals well if we
cultivate if we craft our souls to make
ourselves more immune to that sort of
pressure and to say yeah i could walk
away from you know whatever it is that
these people care about hundreds of
thousands of twitter followers or
whatever it might be
and my life would still be good why well
because
influencing those people that's not what
it's about at the end of the day for me
what it's about is is actually like you
know
pursuing the truth uh and having these
kind of virtues uh i think that's you
know i think that's tough it's admirable
man you don't need to agree with scott
adams oh
i use sam harris as this example all the
time sam consistently gets [ __ ] on by
the people that last week said that they
loved him because he falls on both sides
of the argument a lot of the time you
know you had someone who was anti-woke
anti-trump
anti-blm riot
but anti-biden um
progressive policies and you're like how
who else is holding all of these
opinions at the same time but the reason
that i believe scott genuinely believes
what he says the reason i trust him and
the same reason i trust sam is he pays a
really really high price
to hold those views
i have to presume that he believes what
he is saying because if he didn't why
the [ __ ] would you choose to say that
like why would you decide to go down
this like slow motion car crash
torpedoing of your own audience
it could be a nihilistic yeah maybe look
let's just see how much i can destroy
myself
and philosophers philosophers you read
nietzsche half the time that's a
legitimate psychological hypothesis man
this guy just
wants to watch and burn yeah what's that
what's the thing you want to do there's
some kind of authenticity of really
owning the consequences of your beliefs
you look at a figure like william james
who was william james william james is a
philosopher he's writing in like the
late 1800s in america and he uh has this
really famous essay called the will to
believe which is basically about times
when you um
when you believe things even though you
don't have enough evidence because it's
just an important part of the kind of
vision of the good life that you're
going after
and one point that james makes is it's
not the case that like you can have
consequence free beliefs like taking a
risk with your beliefs and ideas
is just as serious as jumping out of a
plane with a parachute or going on a
rock climbing expedition like there's
there's legitimate
goods at stake with uh your intellectual
life
and so that's why this is hard like this
is why you need to learn some philosophy
and you need to think and practice and
have help because um there there are
costs to getting things wrong but
there's also cost to not trying yeah i'm
not trying to figure out what's right i
was happy to see the agency made it into
the book it's one of the most important
traits that i think that anyone can have
it's something that i try and cultivate
in myself all the time have you got a
story from history about agency that you
can tell me
yeah so the the philosopher that we rely
on in that chapter and we talk about
agency and responsibility as very
closely tied together right uh so the
philosopher we're relying on there is
elizabeth anscombe who i just adore i
love elizabeth anscombe she's a virtue
ethicist middle of the 20th century uh
and she's writing about about human
action right and how we try to figure
out uh when we're acting well when we're
acting wrongly how do we measure that
and one of the huge insights that comes
out of her work is that it really
depends
how we describe or how we tell the story
uh of our action right a lot of things
hang on that so the example that i give
is you know it's a silly example but it
it it illustrates it uh you know i show
up late to a meeting well i can tell the
story
of my action in one way i can say look
oh the traffic was so bad and i tried my
hardest and here i am and you know uh
and in doing so i excuse myself i sort
of say look you know i did everything i
could i you know cared about the right
things and i got it wrong or i can take
responsibility by describing you know
look i i just slept in i didn't care
enough right uh i didn't leave time for
traffic i took a risk and yeah look at
here i am
uh okay so the way that we describe the
way we tell this story of our actions
and they can be simple ones like you
know arriving and i mean they can be
really complex actions that take place
over a long period of time with the
people that we care about
this is going to uh like crucially
determine like whether or not we're
taking responsibility whether
uh our agency is um
sort of being deployed rightly or
wrongly right
so so one thing that we
rely on anscombe and another philosopher
uh bernard williams for is is this idea
of using what williams calls uh morally
thick concepts like virtue terms like
generosity uh or you know uh anger
whatever it might be uh to interrogate
and ask questions about the stories that
we're telling like
am i telling stories that always make me
the hero right and if so are they true
it doesn't seem like they could possibly
be true right
so why do i tell them right how do i go
back and start telling more accurate
stories or start even just asking
questions about my intentions in the
first place right uh so i i think this
is one of the the things that we get you
know from the virtue ethics tradition
from antscombe uh that again can just
sort of practically and does practically
uh change the way that that i present
myself in the world or that i think
about actions that i'm gonna be
undertaking in the future how do i tell
a story that's not just sort of you know
a good story about it how do i tell the
true story about it and what does that
sort of say about me about my character
about my intentions what about
generosity it's an interesting one i had
scott barry kaufman on the show talking
about he's an expert in maslow and he
was talking about the hierarchy of needs
and he was adamant that after
actualization you get to transcendence
and transcendences when you then go
beyond yourself and you give to other
people
how what was the angle that you guys
came to uh charitability or generosity
from
i i uh i've been thinking about this
question for a while because
ever since i've been teaching philosophy
and certainly since we started teaching
god in good life here at notre dame i've
taught peter singer
who has these really interesting
super practical pieces of advice for how
to
make your money into a part of your
moral life and what singer tells his
students at princeton which is
fascinating and i love reading about it
is he's got all these really smart 18 19
year olds
who are also morally serious and who who
care about other people and care about
their moral reasons and he says look
there are a lot of people out there in
the world
whom your money could help more than
your time or volunteer or thoughts and
prayers
like you could literally change the
world you could save people from malaria
if you earn money and then do the hard
thing of committing all of it to these
really efficient ways of uh enhancing
lives
and they'll teach this class and they'll
get you know some students will sign
pledges to to try to pursue a high
income in at least a morally permissible
way so they're not going to become like
drug dealers but they might go work for
a hedge fund or a really big uh banking
unit and then make as much money as
possible and make themselves into a
vehicle by which money is converted from
the economy in the west to these really
needy people elsewhere in the world and
he writes i think it's so revolutionary
to kind of look at charity in that way
and giving in that way because kind of
the story that we've been told around
charity is that
it's it's sort of this
cottage industry that you're supposed to
do that the person that goes and gives
their time at the soup kitchen is that
is the virtue that they have when you
realize through the effect of altruism
movement or like 80 000 rob whitland's
thing that if you are able to be an
absolute force of nature at generating
wealth and then you just decide to give
it away that is that is your best way to
help a lot of other people but it runs
quite counter to this sort of like homey
very kind of homespun uh style charity
that's been a narrative that we've seen
a lot recently
oh yeah no and i mean it weighed a lot
on me because i've read those arguments
and singer makes a really good point
those the children in africa there's
somebody's children in the south sudan
like people love them they matter that
just the the system has been set up in
such a way that um that their lives are
valued much less than the lives of
people directly surrounding us and at
the time
when when paul and i were getting
started with teaching our god in the
good life course uh my youngest brother
was getting ready to go to college and
we were very our parents are really low
income and so the question became like
how much money would i be willing to put
towards my brother getting a really
elite education um and the answer i
didn't have to think very hard about it
at all is like man i would pay double my
my mortgage down payment for for his
college but then you know had this pause
especially as i was teaching our
students that amount of money could
could save on average seven people's
lives would i kill seven people to send
my brother this is the this is the
[ __ ] problem with singer's stuff this
is the problem because as soon as you go
down that there is a boy drowning in the
lake next to you you don't want to get
your shoes wet it's over the next
village it's in the next country
you just every i i struggle to not feel
like an [ __ ] at all all the time but
philosophy's point is to make you feel
like an [ __ ] sometimes so so one of
the things that i got thinking about and
then paul and i started working on
really hard when we got to that chapter
of the book is singer gives a very
practical advice what kind of advice
would a virtue ethicist give that tells
you like no seriously you're kind of
smart 18 19 year old with the capacity
to make a lot of money but also the
capacity to join the peace corps or the
capacity to like start a family
ha like practically speaking how can i
help you figure out how you can uh make
a morally serious difference without
just assuming that um like you know we
can imagine the kind of cultural default
would which is of course give a whole
lot more to people that are biologically
related to you than you give to people
who are far away
and of course whatever you feel is the
right way to spend your money is the
right way to spend your money which is
very unphilosophical or like you can use
philosophy to try to justify the
decisions that you don't want to make
but it's hard for us to it's hard for a
lot of people to decide to change or
morally evaluate their financial plan so
we we wanted to get into that
it's it's a weird one especially when
a modern phenomenon like wealth wealth
acquisition comes crashing up against
kind of this like old dusty or what
feels like an old and dusty
academic subject of philosophy
oh my gosh like i think about this a lot
now you're just getting my me on like
the therapy couch
uh
one thing i think about quite a bit is i
i don't want to be the kind of person
that measures the good life in terms of
money um and we know that from socrates
like don't do that's there lies disaster
um so then you think okay well i'm in my
job at a big corporation how hard should
i negotiate for a pay raise or how often
should i complain about how much i'm
being paid if i literally don't care
about money and my needs are met um and
you might think the answer is none but
then that gives you pause it certainly
gives me pause because you think but
it's also grossly unfair that women are
paid less than men um that some people
who i think is like work is in fact
objectively less economically valuable
get paid more because of who they are
and so you want to fight individually
against those forms of discrimination or
injustice but at the same time want to
hold this paradox in your head of not
wanting to care about money and use it
as a way of keeping score but but you're
also using it as a way of keeping score
on justice so how to resolve that i
think is a puzzle a lot of people
certainly women and people in
marginalized groups are like
dealing with that every single year
it's a weird one
it's an interesting one thinking about
how
how to ethically use money and money
acquisition and
chasing it without becoming captured by
it or without being emotionally invested
in it
yeah it's yeah it is a
talk to me let's say that someone's
quite seduced by the idea of virtue
ethics and wants to make a crack at it
what would you say are the most
accessible books the most the best sort
of introductions where would you get
people to start
i mean like uh i don't know just to plug
our own class here at notre dame we
actually uh have a whole website where
we just put the whole class online
basically
uh or all the texts that we read in the
class online so you can go to
godaddengoodlife.nd.edu
and you can just see sort of how we walk
through texts from the history of
philosophy
we've got a lot of annotated text so you
can read you know aristotle's
nicomachean ethics but you know with
some sort of pointers and some some help
uh to understand kind of the weirder
distinctions that he's making um that's
one place you can start to look i mean
probably the even better place would be
to buy our the good life method book the
book that we wrote based on the class
which is really designed for uh for
readers who are coming at this not as a
college course but as somebody who's
just really curious about starting to
build philosophy into their life and we
have every chapter ends with every
chapter tackles a different kind of uh
question of the good life that comes at
us from philosophy and we start off
little with like how to have better
political disagreements with folks using
plato
um building up to like how to be a
better uh romantic partner and parent
using iris murdoch and virtue ethicists
we talk about work life balance and all
the ways philosophy makes that question
a lot different than you think it is and
then build up to like what are you going
to do about this whole religion thing
what are you going to do about death
um we have a lot of practical exercises
but also just like it's hard to just sit
down and start reading philosophy we
don't recommend that you go to barnes
noble
and buy a nietzsche book and just sit
down and try to read it from beginning
to end
it's gonna be hard because it was
written in a different time and it was
meant to be put in context but one of
the things we do in the book is if
you're just getting started
try to give you all the handholds so
that it feels really like you're making
progress at the right pace and really
understanding things and uh our students
we've taught this material to thousands
of notre dame students right now
um have really loved this system and
it's worked for years with us so so
we're hoping it'll have a much bigger
audience now
well that will be linked in the show
notes below
paul megan we made it we made it to the
end uh thank you very much for coming on
it's been it's been really really
interesting it's nice to hear
a different side of philosophy coming
out and i really appreciate that you
guys are flying the flag for some
sort of re-emerging and lesser-known
philosophers in this modern world so
thank you
thank you chris thank you so much this
is really fun what's happening people
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace